etet Louis Blouin, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Louis, vous avez signé un
tetexte fort intéressant ce mat.
HaHabituellement ce genre de
tetexte, on n'en a vu beaucoup t
ququand j'étais sur les collines
etet lettres genre de texte
coconfirmaient les gens ne
paparlaient pas à visage
dédécouvert. Or, il y a des
dédéputés du parti libéral du
CaCanada qui en ont marre d'être
ououblié depuis la campagne
élélectorale. Je cite de extrais
::
ilil y aurait des livres à écrie
susur comment Monsieur Chrétien,
MoMonsieur Sherret dorloter leur
cacaucus et s'en occuper. Monsir
TrTrudeau, depuis l'élection en
totout cas, elle crée des
mémécontents.
- - Je vous dirai qu'il y a une
cecertaine frustration de voir s
chchoses s'étirait comme cela
dedepuis le scrutin du 20
seseptembre. Deux frustration
prprincipale : elle a toujours s
eueu de réunion officielle du
cacaucus national des libérauxùu
totous les députés se rencontret
popour faire par exemple des
rérétroactions sur la dernière
cacampagne. Il y a des personnes
ququi me disaient qu'on attend
opopérations ou par des électeu,
çaça a une valeur il faut
cocommuniquer cela aux parties.l
fafaut communiquer cela au premr
miministre. La deuxième chose :
ilil y a des décisions qui se
prprennent sans que le caucus st
coconsulté. Exemple : la fin dea
PCPCRE, cela a été annoncé la
sesemaine dernière. Ils disent
ququ'on n'a pas entendu parler e
çaça alors qu'on a vu la citatin
de députés, j'aurais aimé
ququ'elle reste parce que les
pepertinentes. Ils avaient écoué
lele caucus, il leur est mainteu
s's'ils avaient pu l'écouter.
- - Ou par mail réécouter le
cacaucus.
- - Il y a des gens qui se dise,
jeje comptais les cases dans mon
cacalendrier, 62 jours vont être
écécoulés entre le scrutin du 20
seseptembre et la reprise des
trtravaux le 22 novembre. Son
cocomparse la aux années 2015 et
202019, c'est à 44 jours. C'est
plplus long. Il y a des députés
ququi se disent qu'il n'y a pase
raraison que ça prenne autant de
tetemps avant qu'on revienne das
nonos fonctions.
- - Comme si Monsieur Trudeau a
crcréé son nouveau conseil des
miministres qu'il veut le plus
efefficace possible pour aller e
plplus loin possible, possiblemt
dadans son dernier mandat. Comme
sisi les députés, pas été
acaccessoires, mais était moins
ututile dans sa ligne de tir.
- - C'est l'impression que ça
dodonne bien évidemment. Bonne
cacampagne électorale, Monsieur
TrTrudeau, on voit les chefs des
paparties bien occupées. Les
dédéputés travaillent fort aussi
pependant campagne.
DaDans l'ordre des choses, qu'on
fafasse au moins un bilan après
l'l'élection avec les députés
réréélus mais aussi avec ceux qi
onont été défaits. Monsieur
TrTrudeau de toute évidence avat
papas de envie d'en entendre
paparler. D'autre part, c'est ls
dédéputés qui sont le relais du
gogouvernement avec la populati.
QuQuand on prend des décisions i
dodoivent les expliquer. Ce ne
fofont pas parti de la décisionn
n'n'en n'ont pas entendu parler
avavant de lire les journaux,
c'c'est frustrant évidemment. Vs
avavez donné l'exemple de chars
dédéjà très près de leur caucus.
MoMonsieur Trudeau est fraîchemt
réréélu. Il n'est pas dit que ds
unun an ou deux ans il se
reretrouvera pas dans le trouble
etet c'est à ce moment que la
plpluie du caucus devient
inindispensable pour un chef eti
onon mécontente les députés
plplusieurs fois, quand les ches
apappel au secours, ils ont aute
chchose à faire.
- - C'est plus naturel pour note
chchef. Leur donner de
l'l'importance et pas simplement
leleur dire que vous ne comptez
papas.
- - Prendre une décision sans
coconsulter son caucus, c'est
pépérilleux. Souvent, les
dédécisions sont prises par
l'l'entourage du premier ministe
dadans un vase assez clos. Ça dt
êêtre mis au jeu. Ça doit être
didiscuté. Il y a des gens pour
spspinner dans les réunions pour
coconvaincre les récalcitrants.n
mmême temps, comme Michel le di,
c'c'est le lien avec le terrain.
CeCe sont des émissaires dans lr
cicirconscription et il dit ce i
sese passe sur leur terrain. Il
fafaut les consulter. Sur Monsir
TrTrudeau, de mon siège à Québe,
enen laissant assez hésitant.
C'C'est son troisième mandat. Ls
dédéputés dans un premier mandat
ététaient majoritaires. Ils se
titiennent un peu plus les fesss
seserrées et il joue le jeu, mas
rerendu au troisième mandat si
nonous, on le sent hésitant, les
dédéputés le sentent aussi.
CeCela fait des députés beaucoup
plplus bavards et si elle ne prd
papas le contrôle de son caucus
rarapidement, je pense que Louis
vava être pas mal occupé à
ininterroger des députés dans ls
prprochaines semaines.
- - Merci. C'est sur notre sitei
vovous voulez aller lire l'artie
dede Louis Blois un. Ça montre a
frfrustration réelle des député.
DéDéjà parle ouvertement. Merci,
LoLouis.
- - Avec plaisir.
- - On change de capital.
IlIl a eu cette bisbille hier
auau sujet de la santé à Québec.
JeJe vous explique le contexte.
MoMonsieur Barette, c'est plus
fofort que lui, donne son avis r
lala négociation avec les médecs
gégénéralistes. On regarde le
twtweet :
c'c'est un peu agressif d'un cô.
SaSa collègue libéral dit non.
PePetite crise au caucus libéra.
Réunion hier et on va écouter ce
mamatin Madame Anglade qui dit :
j'j'ai expliqué à mon équipe qun
dodoit se serrer les coudes.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE,
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - S'il y a une chose que
jeje ne fais pas, comme vous
popouvez le constater, c'est
dede pas museler mes députés.
AuAu contraire. Contrairement
auaux députés d'en face de
lala Coalition avenir Québec,
momoi, mes députés s'expriment
etet s'expriment librement.
LaLa seule chose que je demande,
c'c'est qu'il y ait une solidaré
sasans faille de la part
dede mes députés.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Je voudrais pas pas faire
d'd'ombrage à Dominique Anglade,
llà, c'est la journée Dominique
AnAnglade, là, qu'elle s'occupe
dede Mme Montpetit puis de
M.M. Barrette. C'est sa journée.
- - Monsieur Legault en a profié
popour envoyer les projecteurs r
MaMadame Anglade. Est-ce que c't
ououblié demain? Où il y a une
gegestion. Monsieur barrette à
nénégocier avec les médecins.
C'C'est sûr qu'on a envie de
sasavoir ce qu'il pense.
- - Il y a beaucoup de choses ds
cecela. Tout le monde a à peu ps
sesept heures. D'abord cela aurt
ddû se régler dans les bureaux e
dodonnées Anglade. Elle a la
réréputation de pas vouloir se
mmêler des chicanes de ses
dédéputés. Elle dit parlez-vous,
réréglez vos affaires. Ça fait n
momoment qu'elle aurait dû le
rérégler. Le froid entre Gaétan
BaBarrette, l'ancien ministre de
lala santé, et Marry m'ont
prpratiqué la porte-parole en
sasanté, dure depuis bien
lolongtemps. Marie mon petit
trtrouve que Gaétan Barrette se
mmêler de ses affaires, il joue
dadans ses plates-bandes. Marie
veveut garder son carré de sable
bibien serré. Elle ne le
coconsultait pas.
MoMonsieur barrette a
efeffectivement pris une positin
quque son propre caucus n'avait
papas pris et c'est ce qui a...
c'c'est solidement Marie
MoMontpetit. Comme conseiller me
didisait c'est comme compter das
toton propre but est assuré quea
lalame du patin est assez proche
dudu visage qu'elle peut couper
auau blessé Carey Price. C'est r
quque ça atteint Dominique Angle
ququi a de la difficulté à gardr
lala discipline dans son caucus.
EnEn même temps, Gaétan Barrett,
ilil est conspué dans le caucus.
BaBarrette c'est tabou pour les
lilibéraux. Monsieur barrette vt
unune opportunité de se refaire.
- - Il va peut-être retraverser.
IlIl nous disait en entrevue etl
paparlait de la santé en entreve
lala semaine dernière.
MoMonsieur barrette, Michel,
dedevient un caillou dans le
sosoulier de Madame Anglade.
- - Très évidemment. Monsieur
babarrette l'a rappelait à l'ore
MaMadame Monpetit.
IlIl ne se mêle pas de ses
afaffaires. Je comprends pourqui
MoMonsieur barrette veut défende
sasa réforme. À chaque fois qu'l
inintervient, il ne s'en prive
papas. Qui donnent leur juste au
PaParti libéral? C'est Marie mon
MoMonpetit ou Monsieur barrette?
IlIl avait beaucoup de visibilié
auauparavant.
- - On la fait nous-mêmes.
- - Monsieur barrette était le
MoMonsieur santé du Parti libér.
OnOn a vu les messages sur Twitr
etet sur ce qu'on ne voit pas ce
ququ'il y a derrière. Je ne doue
papas un seul instant que Monsir
babarrette ne se gênait pas pour
didire à Marie que ça n'a pas
d'd'allure ce que tu dis. On
l'l'avait vu, son côté
papaternaliste, pour employer un
momot gentil à l'endroit par
exexemple de Madame Lamarre.
C'C'est bien, mais il y a la
mamanière. Monsieur barrette ne
chchoisit pas toujours la bonne.
- - La raison pour laquelle
DoDominique Anglade a donné la
tatape sur les doigts de Marie
plplutôt que Gaétan Barrette,
c'c'est que le caucus était
dederrière Gaétan Barrette, la
réréunion de ce matin qui était
plplus importante que celle
d'd'hier, les députés estiment
quque Monsieur barrette a mis en
plplace une réforme qui a été
adadoptée par les libéraux et
ququ'il n'y a personne qui prend
lala balle pour lui. Quand même,
lala réformer dans l'actualité
rérégulièrement. C'est Madame
AnAnglade qui va être obligée de
rérépondre à son caucus.
- - C'est ce que j'allais vous
poposer comme question. Prenons
jujuste la partie négociation ac
leles médecins. Ne parlons pas e
lala restructuration. Sur son
atattitude qu'il voulait avoir
avavec les médecins, est-ce quea
lilibéraux adoptent son attitude
ouou pas? C'est ce qu'on peut
sasavoir. Madame se situe où?
- - C'est une excellente questi.
JeJe pense que Madame Anglade va
didire : écoutez, ce n'est pas a
bobonne façon de faire les choss
paparce que la politique
fifinalement du gouvernement
CoCouillard aura été de ne pas
apappliquer la loi 20 que Monsir
LeLegault semble vouloir apprêtr
àà une nouvelle sauce. J'ai
l'l'impression que la latitude u
PaParti libéral ça va être le de
: : arrêté et assoyez-vous avec
leles médecins pour trouver une
sésélection. Une guerre avec les
mémédecins, on ne la gagne pas
sosouvent, et ça laisse des
séséquelles.
- - C'est le choix de la chef.
IlIl faut qu'on se situe dans ce
dédébat. Est-ce que je suis
plplus...
lala douceur et la lenteur a été
esessayée.
- - C'est ça. C'est le fond de
l'l'histoire. Encore aujourd'hu,
elelle a tergiversé sur cette
ququestion. Quelle est la positn
dudu Parti libéral? La solution,
popour que les 800 000 Québécois
etet accès à un médecin de
fafamille? Elle ne parle pas de
méméthode dure deux méthodes
foforte. Elle laisse tout ça das
unune espèce de flou et le caucs
fafait pression également pour n
didiscuter et ça ne se discute s
enen ce moment.
- - Barrette de la part
s's'empêchait de la parole pendt
leles caucus. Il connaît les
dédétails. L'autre doit être
frfrustré.
JeJe répète : peut-être que ce
n'n'est pas la méthode dure à
ememployer avec les médecins mas
ilil faut avoir une position et
didire : est-ce qu'on veut des
gagains ou pas de gains dans le
nonombre de patients qu'ils ont?
- - Il va falloir qu'il y ait ue
poposition plus claire que cela.
JeJe pense que ça va être une
poposition qui va être à
l'l'encontre de celle de Monsier
LeLegault parce que le Parti
lilibéral est dans l'opposition.
OnOn verra le projet de loi quee
gogouvernement va présenter. Je
susuis convaincu que l'oppositin
vava trouver moyen de dire que e
n'n'est pas la bonne façon de
fafaire.
- - Monsieur Legault dit souvent
quque le lobby est très puissan.
C'C'est l'médecin spécialistes i
esest le lobby le plus puissantt
lele plus riche aussi. Souvent,a
FMFMOQ et le lobby remarque, cei
ququi passe après et qui récolt.
OnOn voit vraiment et on va voir
dede quel bois se chauffe la FMQ
dadans ce dossier. Et l'impressn
ququ'on a chez François Legaultt
onon a sans doute fondé sur la
ququestion, l'opinion publique e
soson côté et veut mater les
mémédecins.
- - C'est très intéressant. Ils
onont sont effectivement et les
gegens veux qu'on a une ligne de
avavec les médecins.
LeLes médecins commencent à parr
etet on s'aperçoit que c'est pe-
êêtre un peu plus compliqué que
cecela. Il a des médecins qui st
plplus à l'hôpital au Québec etn
OnOntario. Le diable est dans ls
dédétails. Michel&
- - Il faut voir d'où vient la
sisituation. Si on fait
l'l'historique, les médecins ont
étété forcés pour une grande
papartie d'aller travailler dans
leles hôpitaux. Un moment donné,
onon avait imposé à tous les
mémédecins de moins de 10 ans ds
prpratiques un certain nombre de
cece qu'on appelle les activités
mémédicales particulières. On ls
obobligeait à aller à l'hôpital
popour faire de l'urgence. Il au
unun déplacement vers les
hhôpitaux.
LeLe système est devenu très
cecentré à l'hôpital. On veut
dédéfaire cela. C'est le
gogouvernement à l'historique qu